boa noite obrigado época voltará a
pilotar aqui que eu queria falar hoje
era contar uma história
não tanto sobre o campo como essa raiva
que é mas é da investigação da ciência
que se faz para conseguir ter novas
terapias nove metros pra tratar essa
doença e não trabalho é feito por muita
gente aqui no porto com o costa falou
nos alimentam trabalhou internacional
que contribui para essa pessoa
o fator e quero falar sobre isto porque
contar a história história do prêmio
nova gestão no que está no prêmio nobel
de medicina foi atribuído a uma
descoberta do seu cancro e foi atribuído
de outubro foi anunciado uma nova
abordagem com os cientistas o americano
de mel em sã e outro por mês só com om e
receberão os prêmios por uma ponte
coberta escrita que é da terapia do
cancro através da inibição da evolução
imunitário negativa que o serviço não é
isso que também explicar é como é que
chegaram a descoberta porque foi
atribuído o prémio nobel ea óbvia mental
que viaja muito porque é uma área de
investigação que não vai mostrando a
trabalhar noutro evento aqui no porto
então é nesta nesta frase que está no
site do comitê do nobel é ensinar o
sistema imunitário sistema imunitário
você estava em até 1 um canoísta que o
nosso corpo tem para iluminar organismos
estranhos num como bactérias ou vírus
que possam causar a doença e não é
concedido por células votar aqui
explicar como se fosse uma prova de
forma a alcançar a obra falar e
patronais corpo sangue os sítios e e
enchimento que encontrei um patogênico
seja uma bactéria ou vírus ou outra
qualquer o tipo do microorganismo vem
queremos possibilitar a predominar é
ficar mesmo para evitar que haja
conversa
são processos podem demorar a ser
enviados não havendo qualquer doença
possa ver uma luta do sistema imunitário
paulo havia determinado o excesso é foco
então um cancro é uma doença com todos
sabem que não é causada por o gênio dos
39 contra o evento vai colocar a questão
junto a questão vá se lá por quem os
enfrenta 14 respiratórias o que causa
uma doença
o cantador de histórias no nosso corpo
então como é que o sistema militar e foi
desenvolvido para combater organismos
estranhos vai combater também o canto
inferior já prevê nova descida o que
explica o cantor tem uma particularidade
a vaa uma doença depende mutações
genéticas que vão levar então é o
crescimento dessas células receitas do
nosso corpo e 11 estações genéticas pra
quem pode explicar melhor o que isto é
gelson tão importante no havaí é uma
mulher que está apresentando as células
do corpo
só quando nós chegamos damos com um
conjunto do ano
queremos ter um enorme só para dar uma
idéia só 46 volumes que herdamos visitas
do papa e três da mãe
são 21 10 x mais aberta mais
simplificados e tudo isso inclui 6 mil
milhões de produção manual de instruções
para fazer um ser humano enorme e é aqui
que ocorre junto ações que podem levar
ao aparecimento do cancro e este genoma
que o que não te dá ao conjunto dos anos
que nós temos para fazer o ser humano é
incluiu que em 2010 seguir é um processo
que finalmente controlava a sair quando
não só todos os jogos nós próprios 29
anos
mas eu não tô te vá mesmo tempo é existe
uma criança de controlo que fazem por
exemplo que um gênio da insulina só seja
possível nas selvas do país cresça
enquanto o gênio da mini usina que é uma
proteína que a atração das músicas a
presença dos músicos e 100 da insulina
não produz insulina ou joga pro primeira
fase as páginas e veicular aos eventos
na área mas não é só a copa é valorizar
o cancro transição é que cada divisão
celular que ocorrem são todos de 800
mostram que aquelas duas filhas 50
habitações mais ou menos vão ocorrer
isto quer dizer que também é responsável
sim vamos ter 50 habitações e vamos
pensar no nosso corpo tem 30 milhões de
milhões de alga 30 13 30 horas a
contratação nós temos no corpo é enorme
e se fosse uma pessoa que cada vez que
os autos deveriam ver nossa conta com do
sal com músicos de origem até formavam
ser um centavo dos casos 13 milhões das
mutações e então é hora de colocar aqui
em são josé dos campos está todo lá já
contactou no caso tratava de um
mecanismo de controle contra o kobenhavn
faz com que trata da divisão celular nós
a mutações muita agitação da quarta
turma acontecem estas mutações agora
porque elas não não não não causam
cancro logo dentro das pessoas nem
propiciar várias razões primeiro zelaya
numa das celas tenso
em 2010 nós a só dez por cento daquelas
letras é que são importantes para fazer
parte dos projetos
então muitas mutações a qualquer local
que não fazem nada
outra aspecto importante é que os 21 e
os erros são alguns confrontos associado
ao cancro a indicação de voto mas com
quatro décadas e ficaram genes
específicos
por exemplo vamos pensar o brca1 se
sabia falar 10 que capital acreana
não é qualquer 06 08 se fixam atraso e
com alterar o funcionamento daquelas
salas
por isso o que sabe hoje em dia qualquer
professor está um processo complexo
porque envolve a 1% das ações mas não é
capaz é uma casa e agora é por que
tantos canto pode levar as contribuições
primeiro é a composição genética na
verdade e sabemos que 100 do berço é um
exemplo
a família acha que pessoas era um jejum
da mãe do pai que já têm uma mutação
naquela zona
então já a partida já tem um algo que
precisa para o tratamento do cancro em
algumas situações que é perguntas
aleatórias que eu tava frio atacado a
facadas um celta de vigo vai ver um time
com o poder público então nesses gêneros
para funcionamento da célula para aí
para cavar o cancro
depois é o terceiro com o terceiro
aspecto
eu acho que a china já fez as mutações
podem ocorrer talvez a palavra ser
aumentada no mutações ou exposição a
personagem da minha tarde pensando na
seleção para ver letterman fumo tabaco
hotel othon pessoa tudo é tudo isso faz
com que o que aumenta problemas de
câmbio e alimenta programava aumenta com
a idade
na prática o que se passa à volta do
sistema imunitário então temos mostrado
é normal que por este grande que eu fui
agora devastou a arsal da inscrição
a gente entrou agentes ambientais
levantam aparecimento do sol os campos
são os anormais e que passa com estas
mutações vão como gêmeos são os
fragmentos da veia que codificam as
proteínas católicos têm um código
genético para produzir proteínas como
influir numa mina
essas mutações vocês vão para proteínas
estranhos e aí que se habilitarem
entregação porque são problemas que não
existiam naquele lance jonas com um
conjunto de 200 anos nos quais quando
ocorrem muitas horas nas telas
vamos ter apenas que o nosso sistema
imunitário nunca viu na vida você então
vou pensar que estão aqui estão a braços
com um agente estranho 111 são pedro
acontece outro tipo de gente
então em trair o sistema imunitário
deixou os bons sons células que
patrulham as copas a pouco que vão
tentar essa chapa antes vão desenvolver
uma resposta imunitária contra essas
células estão crismo tempo tanto o
processo foi chamado em 19 lances já
criou essa definição já uma da amoreira
décadas e é uma boa via para um bom
exemplo a variân provas científicas
destas normas para um caso que é fácil
observar é quando há pessoas que estão
em 19 anos por exemplo todos a pensarem
em doentes que recebem transplante de
órgãos e que são tratados como nas
pessoas por exemplo nem conseguindo a
vitória fica debilitado ou doentes da
silva que em 1900 querida e se não será
prorrogado maior de desenvolverem cancro
é uma boa indicação nos casos em doentes
que o cemitério está lá para nos ajudar
também por dia não só os micro
organismos externos também por ser salva
semelhantes algumas pessoas no nosso
corpo
então mas se não você nem sempre
funcionava em uma briga com flamengo
simplesmente ou no caso
então am que já vamos falar mais à
frente porque aí que entra o secretas
que levaram ó ó prêmio nobel gostando
mas o conhecimento campo e as
descobertas das mutações de varejo como
freio ver se a um eletrocardiograma
concessão e portanto foi o descobertas
novas terapias novas modalidades para
tratar o os vários tipos de cancro
isso levou o aparecimento do sul 11
inclusive a que chama terapia molecular
dirigida
basicamente é o que diz o seguinte se
chama os campos têm uma mutação num gene
que vai para uma proteína também está
notava então poderemos desenvolver um um
medicamento qualquer método que possa só
bloquear aquela proteína e num lugar
para já os problemas normais que é uma
das grandes vantagens por exemplo que a
equação a quimioterapia ea quimioterapia
um metro tratamento em que os fim a
bloquear a divisão à chave e divisão
matar células que deverão movimentar só
quero viver assim preferem fazendo um
monte mas só passar no corpo também que
vem com os jogos o que eu gosto do
cliente final o gloss e por isso quando
faz um programa por quimioterapia não
teve muitas chances com várias adversos
que são bastante irritante
ele é tranquilo agora dirigida evitar
isso é tratar o cancro só atingindo o
cancro e sem afetar os animais em um bom
exemplo disso é um tomara que o pessoal
da costa que o trabalho que ela assumia
pronto para assumir aquelas minha
eletrônica que há uns 30 anos atrás a
surgir doentes adultos duas brigadas nos
procurou no tratamento de quimioterapia
no mundo jesus não conseguiam furar as
duas pessoas tinham em média de vida de
57 anos com a investigação foi feita foi
descoberta uma mutação específica nas
ruas nem lá crónica de final 2 mil
passageiros desenvolver um medicamento
que destruiu essa proteína mutada isso é
uma terapia molecular dirigida que
resultou numa por um prolongamento da
vida das duas conseguiu eletrônica que
hoje em dia muito deus eu só tento
encontrar um ano 2000 mais ou menos
princípio as minhas motivações que estão
vivendo hoje em dia tem uma semana livre
com hassan é igual é normal
por isso é o essencial que é feita a
travessia por vezes nesses avanços meta
estipulada já funciona para todo o tipo
de cancro não funciona pronto pra o
outro é um dos problemas do dom cobb um
dia com esta palavra que a edificação da
violência no campo
aquela conquista é uma doença que
enfrenta seja tem um céu as origens de
frente têm formas de nos manifestar na
forma de 30 por isso são sempre precisa
de novos conhecimentos pra tentar tratar
outros tipos branco ao encontrar os
melhores crônicas que continua a causar
bastantes problemas na fila
então é a volta do sistema imunitário
costumo escutar em conversa gravada por
células malignas em londres a pouco nós
já sabíamos há muito tempo que os
tumores com os controles do fonesa
microscópio não só composta unicamente
pela chamada ramos que também existem
salas ditas normais elas contêm mutações
genéticas telas que aparentemente não
não serão os processos de cicatrização e
alguns social estamos a passar o sistema
imunitário têm sala cheia humanitário
mas o tumor continuar o processo e e aí
que foi feita uma das descobertas que eu
aprenda nova foi de que as células de
cancro inibiam as células do sistema
imunitário é tal regulação imunitária
negativa que foi o tal que plantava
nesta no esquema fez a elas produzem uma
proteína ou duas proteínas foi descobrir
ou do dmlu descobriu uma proteína
chamada pv e 1
o tofu com 11 outra molécula semanas e
terá quatro funcionários que trabalhavam
independentemete descobriu moléculas que
correspondem aos sinais do top 10
mulheres quando elas cantam porque
tinham fazer o pessoal tem uma história
não esconder então é que eu vou
continuar a investigar já chegaram a
primeira e mais do laboratório mas pode
aplicar usando uma anticorpos que inibem
aos sinais negativos
estamos a falar da inibição da regulação
imunitário negativa que foi ministro
antecedente copa conseguiam bloquear os
sinais negativos e sistema imunitário
começaram a reagir contra o cancro
e isso foi feito em animais com um
sucesso enorme sucesso e jovens em
eventos acontecem em maior ou seja uns
tipos de cancros procópio tem funcionado
a planejou 21 com o papel que é uma
norma é quem é um time muito agressivo
que com esperança de vida muito curta
para monte do vento mas com este
tratamento de imunoterapia contra estas
proteínas
temos doentes com respostas para a
clássica consegue atender a vários anos
de vida continuam vivos da cultura da
paz e é esse o tipo de cancro 11 roth
por cancro do pulmão são todos
implemento preciso mais investigação
neste momento que estavas tantã em é
porque estamos a médica que não estava
legal quimioterapia nem a gente coloca
tipo de terapia celular e um kia também
uma área que me interessa eu nunca vi
que o nosso trabalho nós cantamos a
investigar este tipo transbordassem prom
reformas que são tipos de cancro de
células do sangue nas quais também não
existem terapias dirigidas e eficiente
então esperamos que com esta é com esta
abordagem que consigamos ter nessa fase
pequenas confecções conseguir terá novos
meios para tratar a estes tipos de
doenças e para terminar só quer deixar
com palavras é preciso pra chegarmos a
esta festa é sucesso de crítica baseada
em vários fatores importantes é o rigor
ou seja fazer as prévias sejam
importante que sejam bem feitas para que
possamos descobrir ao do novo álbum
cento e as ruas completamente educação
científica e de difícil solução que
moram há seis meses ou anos
sorte às vezes existem as descobertas
que ocorrem mesmo sem motor de provas ou
seja trabalha numa hipótese é afinal uma
coisa boa pra só faz parte ea
persistência seja sempre ter muito
é força de vontade pra continuar a
trabalhar e continuar a explorar é o
descaso os mecanismos do evento cancro
expressas encontrar algo que seja tenha
endereço a conversão e nós é um trabalho
comum nas nossas equipas que nossos
estudantes como vários membros do
instituto
já a nível internacional o movimento
campo voltou a colocar o santos na final
e por último trabalho e envolvimento
respeito por todos os dias que vem 10
para testar esta doença que causa tanto
sofrimento
obrigado obrigado obrigado por baixo
[Música]